[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue ravi de vous retrouver pour d'autres
rendez vous quotidien vous connaissez la
formule quatre invités et autant de
points de vue sur quatre sujets qu'on
découvre tout de suite en images la
france n'a plus de ministre de
l'intérieur depuis ce matin mais c'est
la sphère de quelques jours nous dit le
porte parole du gouvernement
tout ça fait quand même un peu désordre
y at il encore un pilote dans l'avion on
se posera la question
et puis nous parlerons des retraités qui
manifestent aujourd'hui en france à
l'appel de neuf organisations sont ils
les maltraiter du pouvoir ont-ils raison
de protester comme ils le font vous nous
donnerez votre point de vue nous
parlerons aussi de la procréation
médicalement assistée pour les couples
de lesbiennes et les femmes seules deux
personnalités importantes de droite
gérard larcher valérie pécresse disent
qu'ils ne sont pas opposés à condition
qu'on mette un certain nombre de
garde-fous est ce que ça veut dire que
c'est déjà plié la pma puis la gpa
on en parlera et puis on parlera aussi
de la loi pacte c'est le nom du nouveau
projet de bruno le maire le ministre de
l'économie qui prévoit notamment de
vendre les participations de l'état dans
quelques grandes sociétés comme la
française des jeux angie ou aéroports de
paris est ce que c'est une bonne idée et
ben on verra ça ensemble avec nos quatre
invités bonsoir christophe de voogd vous
êtes historien vous enseigne à sciences
po
la rhétorique politique et l'histoire
des idées politiques et votre dernier
ouvrage en collaboration s'appelle où va
la démocratie et ça a été publié chez
plon philippe meyer est là aussi bon
soir vous êtes journaliste écrivain
animateur d'une nouvelle esprit public
disponible en podcast chaque 10 mai en
pleine campagne de financement
participatif sur qu'est-ce qui ce bang
bang et aura donc je pense que mon
chapeau à la sorte est en pleine
campagne de financement participatif je
vous préviens ici on prend 5% vers qu'on
n'est pas chez verte et les raisins mais
enfin on est quand même ravi de vous
accueillir votre dernier livre les gens
de mon pays a été publié chez robert
laffont
matteo jose alberti et là aussi bonsoir
bonsoir on est ravis de vous accueillir
dans point de vue vous êtes journaliste
rédacteur en chef du site putsch qui est
un site internet surtout dédié à
l'actualité culturelle
oui et aussi pour animer les débats et
aussi pour animer les débats
ça tombe bien puisqu'on va rendre à voir
ce soir et guillaume tabard elle
merci de nous avoir rejoint guillaume
vous êtes l'éditorialiste politique du
figaro on retrouve votre contrepoint
tous les jours de la semaine et vous
officiez aussi sur radio classique dans
la matinale de guillaume durand
entre autres activités on parle tout de
suite de l'actualité politique et ce
matin a eu donc eu lieu la non passation
de pouvoir entre gérard collomb ministre
de l'intérieur démissionnaire et le
premier ministre edouard philippe qui va
assurer l'intérim
le ministre de l'intérieur était
tellement pressé de partir qu'on n'a pas
eu le temps de trouver un remplacement
un remplaçant pardon mais ça ne va faire
que de quelques jours explique que
benjamin griveaux le porte parole du
gouvernement
guillaume tabard je lisais votre
contrepoint ce matin et vous dit la
chose suivante
emmanuel macron peut-il se remettre de
l'humiliation que lui inflige le premier
des macros nist
le voilà relégué au rang de spectateur
et bt des caprices ou des calculs
personnels de ce qu'il a nommé comme on
connaît votre modération on se dit que
si vous écrivez ça c'est que c'est
vraiment sérieux
écoutez j'ai essayé de faire juste un
constat le constat c'est que dans cette
affaire de démission de gérard collomb
comme dans celle de nicolas hulot il ya
un mois le président n'a pas été m
ni du calendrier ni des événements il ne
voulait pas que je me disais que le gie
partie les parties il ne voulait pas que
sont les intérieurs partout en tout cas
pas dans ces conditions il est parti et
dans les deux cas
emmanuel macron n'a rien pu faire ni
pour les retenir ni pour les dissuader
ni même pour gérer l'événement est ça
qui est terrible pour un pouvoir
politique
après un rapide a inscrit 15 qui incarne
directement la maîtrise la conduite des
affaires de l'état
quand il n'est maître de rien eh ben
c'est c'est terrible hélas encore plus
terrible parce que ben on sait bien et
tout le monde la halle l'a répété depuis
ces derniers jours gérard collomb
c'était le premier cas avait cru en
macron c'est le premier des macros nice
peut être même macro 17 avant l'heure
quand on voit comment il gérait la ville
de de lyon et que oui quand c'est jean
luc mélenchon laurent wauquiez ou marine
le pen qui table sur macron grc par
avant tout casser le jeu politique
quand c'est celui qui a cru en vous qui
vous dit bye-bye je m'en vais ce que
j'ai mieux à faire que de rester dans ce
gouvernement là c'est plus difficile 200
m
christophe de voogd galles feu à la
maison écoutez je crois que c'est quand
même difficile de dire le contraire
en tout cas il ya un début d'incendié
tout le problème est de savoir si c'est
vraiment le commencement de la fin ou la
fin du commencement comme disait l'autre
je crois que dans cette affaire
évidemment ce qui est peut-être plus
grave encore c'est ce qu'a dit kolon
dans sa passation de pouvoir fausse
passation de pouvoir c'est à dire qu'il
a fait un constat sur l'état de la
société française qui était pas
spécialement flatteur non plus un bilan
sur la sécurité par exemple
c'est assez curieux pour un ministre de
l'intérieur sortant qui en général 10 gt
gt génial non je crois que alors je
voudrais pas qu'on passe si vous êtes
comme un peu tendance à le faire on est
passé du maquereau loving pendant des
mois aux maquereaux bashing sur un peu
tous les plateaux je vous serais très
bien que moi j'étais je disais à
l'époque du mâcon lovering wait and see
et on dise comment il est génial et puis
maintenant j'entends que la peur presque
envie par esprit de contradiction de
dire que l roi n'est pas encore tout à
fait nous il est juste torse nu si vous
voyez quoi je fais allusion et et qu' il
l'a encore mais il faut qu'il fasse très
vite qu'il trouve surtout le moyen
approprié
il a peut-être encore des moyens de
rebondir grâce à la force des
institutions n'oublions jamais qui est
quand même la cinquième derrière mais il
faut absolument la qu'ils le soient
appelle une anthologie en kg j aurais
truc il renverse qu'il fasse de
nécessité vertu et qu'ils renversent la
vapeur très vite avant la vie en
s'adressant directement aux français et
en arrêtant de passer par via les
réseaux sociaux
monsieur machin madame machin et qu'ils
adressent des yeux dans les yeux aux
français alors pour l'instant ils
passent par monsieur machin
enfin pas tout à fait monsieur machin
parce que c'est benjamin griveaux c'est
quand même le porte parole du
gouvernement qui à la sortie du conseil
des ministres nous a expliqué qu'elle
était l'état d'esprit du président de la
république et ça n'est pas forcément une
surprise tout va bien regarder s'il a
enfin souligné que rien de ce qui se
passe depuis 48 heures ne s'apparente à
une crise politique l'état fonctionne
des transformations sont engagés le
gouvernement est parfaitement à sa tâche
ce que nous traversons il ya des sujets
strictement personnelles et il a appelé
chaque membre du gouvernement à savoir
s'élever au dessus des intérêts
particuliers
j'ai marivaux qui a dû être décorée pour
l'occasion donc ya pas de crise
politique en tout cas c'est ce qui nous
dit tout ce qui se passe ne s'apparente
pas à une crise de cet ordre ce n'est
pas l'avis de gérard larcher le
président du sénat précédent les
républicains du sénat
il s'en expliquait ce matin sur france
info il ya une crise politique au sens
moral
c'est à dire qu'il ya vrais doutes sur
l'autorité du chef de l'état et du
premier ministre
c'est sans doute un doute sur la manière
de gouverner cette manière un peu
verticale êtes vous aussi habité par ce
doute philippe meyer vous avez dit tout
à l'heure c'était une non passation de
pouvoir et je me demande si pas pour le
plaisir de faire un jeu de mots mais
s'il faudrait pas dire que c'est une
passation de nom pouvoir parce que il me
semble que derrière la démission de
gérard collomb il ya quelque chose qui
est extrêmement intéressant qui est un
échec
en tout cas pour le moment du maquereau
nice mais de ce qu'il avait annoncé vous
souvenez quand il avait annoncé qu'on
allait reprendre la pratique américaine
des dépouilles et que le président de la
république si c'était lui ferait en
sorte que tous les directeurs
d'administration centrale serait qu'on
ferait d'accord avec la ligne politique
ce qu'il en soit n'est mais parce qu'en
valeur oui mais c'est pas scandaleux
c'est une pratique que nous n'avons pas
beaucoup mais qui en tout cas une fois
qu'elle est annoncée avant l'élection et
que le celui qu'il annonce est élu c'est
une pratique qui peut paraître normal ça
ne s'est pas passé du tout et on l'a vu
dans un cas notamment cette histoire du
prélèvement à la source ou le directeur
général je ne sais plus de quoi il est
directeur général mais il est directeur
général des finances publiques
probablement un qui prend votre argent
ce service merci beaucoup pour ça que
j'oublie son nom facilement mais il
voulait le prélèvement à la source et il
a eu le prélèvement à la source et dans
la sphère benalla on a vu dans beaucoup
de l'audience de des commissions des
deux commissions celle de l'assemblée
celle du sénat on a vu que par exemple
le préfet de police et le ministre
l'intérieur était sur des lignes qui
étaient passablement divergentes pour ne
pas dire quelquefois contradictoires et
il me semble qu'il ya quelque chose qui
se passe à quoi emmanuel macron n'est
pas parvenu et pour le moment ne
parvient pas à s'attaquer
c'est la résistance de la
technostructure aux élus et franchement
il me semble que derrière la démission
de gérard collomb il faut voir plus que
un problème de caractère ou même un
problème de désaccords sur la façon de
gouverner avec le président de la
république et je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose de ce genre qui expliquerait
d'ailleurs ce que vous avez relevé
c'est à dire le fait qu'il a fait un
discours pour dire eh ben ça ne marche
pas juste la situation est grave et
peut-être de structure il en est le
meilleur représentant lui-même peut pas
l'oublier non plus il est inspecteur des
finances s'est muée le mac on m'a dit ok
merci d'accord mais je sais justement
probablement pour ça sachant ce que
c'est qu'ils voulaient la métrage douce
et y'a pas mieux que c'est dans les
familles qu'on retrouve le plus d'
assassin mais je trouve qu'il ya
personnellement ça me pose des questions
et à mon avis c'est toute cette
situation met à nu les faiblesses de la
vème république dans les sens que c'est
vrai que la vème république est forte
parce qu'on a une verticalité et que
c'est pas une verticalité de la saison
macron plutôt que la saison roland de
sarkozy etc on centralise pendant cinq
ans toutes les décisions et après pas
contre le monde entre temps changent et
surtout de maintenant où tout se passe
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux on a eu
aussi dans ces derniers jours on a le
besoin d'entendre les
les citoyens d'une façon différente et
la chose un corps qui m'a laissé plutôt
perplexe c'est maintenant dans cette non
passation de pouvoir ou de ne pouvoir
passer enfin bref était le fait que le
ministre de l'intérieur de couvre que
la france va mal que les périphéries
sont en brésil et je me dis mais comment
c'est possible que amis sur un terrain
qui appartient à un gouvernement qui a
une majorité écrasante dans un parlement
il n'a pas pu prendre des décisions
avant pour au moins agir parce qu on a
rappelé que de toute façon
l'alerté terroriste est très élevé on a
eu des morts encore donc des agressions
qui sont pratiquement quotidiennes voilà
je trouve que toute cette situation
devrait faire réfléchir sur la
possibilité de mettre des contrepoids du
point de vue du contrôle je ne sais pas
si de la de la manne des minorités
plutôt que d'autres formes de contrôle
et qui existe dans les grandes
démocraties que les états unis comme la
dent bretagne etc
deuxième sujet pour rebondir sur ce qui
vient d'être dit en tant que maire de
lyon que artisans de la grande métropole
le ministre de l'intérieur a fait tout
ce qu'il a pu déjà comme maire de lyon
et aussi comme lise l'intérieur pour que
la france périphérique soit de plus en
plus périphériques mais peut se demander
pourquoi cette précipitation de gérard
collomb à vouloir quitter le pouvoir
il a dit à nos confrères du télégramme
c'est un successeur le progrès pardon
nos confrères du progrès si un
successeur est trouvé dans la nuit
je lui aurais passé les pouvoirs au
ministère de l'intérieur et oui je
pourrais revenir à lyon comme si c'était
une question d'heures comment est-ce que
vous expliquer cette attitude de l'ex
ministre de l'intérieur guillaume tabard
force cavités ont la clé les lyonnaises
plus qu'elle n'est nationale vous dansez
dansez dans plus de 7 c en 2020 les
élections municipales à lyon il a le
temps oui mais gérard collomb est
attachée et sans nécessairement à sa
ville autant que sa ville lui et lui
attacher or depuis qu'il a quitté
physiquement lyon même s'il se remet
régulièrement tout cas depuis qu'il a
quitté les rênes et de la mairie et de
la métropole mais les choses avancent et
sans lui et entre ben malgré tout
l'usure d'une équipe qui en place depuis
un bout de temps
et puis aussi le fait que après que l'on
y compris ses propres adjoint ses
propres bras droit et bras gauche qui
l'a mis à la tête et de la ville et de
la métropole ont pris aussi un peu leur
autonomie je pense qu'il a senti que
cette ville se dérober un peu sous ses
pieds et qu'il a eu peur de ne plus
pouvoir y revenir
ou de ne plus pouvoir contrôler sa vie
et son développement dès maintenant et à
lyon plus encore qu'ailleurs on est déjà
dans la préparation des municipales
le fait aussi que on dit que la femme
gérard collomb et des ambitions
municipales que lui a voulu accompagner
etc et qui crée un climat calme vision
assez détestable au sein de la vie
politique lyonnaise tout ça crée quelque
chose qui ne tournait plus rond à lyon
et c'est dire si je veux pas rater le
coche en 2020 il faut que au plus vite
je me réinstalle dans ma ville et tant
pis pour macron en vous donner votre
point de vue bien sûr sur les réseaux
sociaux sur lefigaro.fr sur twitter
hashtag figaro life hashtag point de vue
thomas nous dit emmanuel macron n'a pas
besoin de ce départ pour s'affaiblir
tout seul
monsieur babineau probablement
pseudonyme le dit la sphère benalla a
écorné l'image de gérard collomb il
essaye désormais de maîtriser son destin
jlr nous dit trois ministres ont déjà
quitté le gouvernement en peu de temps
à un moment il va bien falloir se poser
les bonnes questions car c'est ce qu'on
essaie de faire cher j'ai l'air il ya un
internaute qui nous parle de benalla
christophe de voogd il ya eu cet été
benalla hulot maintenant collomb est ce
que c'est juste une mauvaise passe où
est-ce que ça commence à devenir un
système est ce que vous voyez une
cohérence entre ces trois événements
outre le fait qu'ils sont tous les trois
négatifs pour le pouvoir
la cohérence et la mauvaise réaction
dans les trois cas du président c'est à
dire qu'il a mal géré les trois que les
trois affaires et qu'il a été mis devant
le fait accompli par les trois qui ont
fait des scores une bêtise chose mais
peu importe mais qu'ils l'ont mis devant
le fait accompli et donc comme de
rappelons-nous la fameuse phrase maître
des horloges line les plus joueurs quand
même revenir sur deux choses d'une part
rendu hommage à un excellent journal
pour ce qu'il a fait car la démission de
colomb si je vous souhaite bien c'est
dans le figaro qu'elle a été annoncée
et je crois que ça n'a pas peu contribué
au scénario enfin je veux dire au
déroulement la chronologie de cette
crise et deuxièmement je pense quand
même que la question de l'autre
guillaume et comme un reste demeure
pourquoi cette date qu'il va y retourner
à lyon on peut le comprendre qui n'est
pas la france périphérique on est bien
d'accord qui n'ont vraiment c'est le
contraire on est bien amusé voilà pour
en finir avec la france paye c'est
vraiment l'autre grande ville
finalement et et c'est l'autre capitale
des gaules certes mais c'est d'autres
capitales et je me demande quand même
cette hâte
vous avez pas d une question rhétorique
que vous savez c'est un peu je suis un
peu malade démo vous l'avez dit pourquoi
est ce qui se passe dans la tête des
français je crois c'est justement la
question du pourquoi
pourquoi cette protection si longue de
bena la cepal affaires pénales mais
pourquoi cette protection si longue
pourquoi cette hâte oui ce que je veux
dire et la question du pourquoi elle est
terrible parce que c'est la question qui
mine puisque élections du pourquoi donne
immédiatement prises au soupçon
donc je crois qu'on est qu'au début de
la faire et qu'il faudra un jour que le
président je reviens ça s'explique sur
ce pour quoi et pas seulement le commet
beaucoup pourquoi parce qu'il ya aussi
le le pourquoi de notre nouveau
président de l'assemblée nationale
pourquoi s'accrocher à ce point à
quelqu'un il ya une méchante affaire
pourquoi la sphère de françoise nyssen
pourquoi la nomination de philippe
besson comme consul général tout en
expliquant que ça a rien à voir avec le
fait que philippe besson a écrit une
hagiographie du président tout ça est
extrêmement des rues du grand est
d'accord vous déroulez le guen je crois
que l'opinion conversation je l'écouté
je comprends rien je regarde iront à
derniers mois là dessus matin justement
j'ajouterai un pourquoi pourquoi
premier ministre aussi à n'a pas exclu
qu'il pourrait porter candidat pour les
municipal de sa ville quelle est cette
envie de quitter le gouvernement
et est ce qu'il y à une crainte pour les
européennes par exemple parce que bon le
résultat on en a vu circuler les
premiers sondages ils sont pas si
négative pour la république en marche
mais quand même ils sont pas
réjouissants voilà est-ce que quelqu'un
pense déjà à l'après comment dire bon
les européennes finalement sur les
européennes lundi voiture non pas par
contre chacun de vous sait pas ce que je
fais ça je ne peux pas refuser la
question mais si je ne m'abuse c'est toi
que je vais parler par dessus tout j'ai
su que vous vous arrêtiez parce que
certains sachets ou dans des boîtes
émission donc je me dis que vous allez
finir par me laisser le dernier point
est donc mais non parce que jadis
libérale-nationale accordé à charlas
d'amour vaudois doivent probablement
servir à masquer les pourquoi j'ai fait
vraiment le mot de la fin cc c'est vous
qui avez gagné le mot de la fin non le
mot de la fin il est pour les
internautes du figaro puisque c'est la
question du jour sur lefigaro.fr le
départ de gérard collomb a faibli ti la
présidence d' emmanuel macron bas c'est
assez compréhensible assez logique
exactement vous êtes 75% à nous dire oui
et pour ceux qui s'inquiéteraient de cet
affaiblissement
voici les dernières nouvelles du
président le chef de l'état est en train
de d'inaugurer le mondial de
l'automobile et il a déclaré qu' il
avait son cap qu'il était tenu que le
gouvernement était au travail et que
tout le reste n'était que péripéties
nous voilà rassurés autre sujet qui font
les 25 % qui pensent qu'ils se
maintenait la con n'est pas affaiblie
par ces départs à la lehman 5% sur sur
le vaincu de 23 mille votants soit sûr
et surtout toucher non si vous m'ayez
que nous dit cette fois-ci voltaire je
vous coupe la parole et c'est définitif
si dense et le micro beaucoup car nous
allons parler des retraités
neuf organisations de retraités appelé
leurs adhérents à descendre dans la rue
on le sait les retraités ou plusieurs
motifs de satisfaction l'augmentation de
la csg pour 7 million et demi d'entre
eux et puis la désindexation
de leur pension qui a été annoncé alors
même que l'inflation est de retour
on les entend protester et face à ça il
ya un gouvernement qui est droit dans
ses bottes et qui dit mais ils sont
plutôt privilégier donc il est normal
qu'ils participent à l'effort
est ce que c'est encore audible ce genre
de discours guillaume tabard
c'est pas faux statistiquement on va
dire que globalement en termes de
patrimoine par exemple les retraités
sont plutôt et c'est logique que plus
favorable le ventre dans une situation
plus favorable que les actifs oui après
je pense le grand problème et c'est une
des erreurs que commettre toujours les
politiques c'est de regarder les choses
de manière statique de regarder le
patrimoine des retraités leur niveau de
vie de comparer à d'autres lire va être
donc ils sont plus près ils sont
privilégiés par rapport à d'autres donc
il faut rééquilibrer sa sauf que le
premier système de jaillir de
péréquation de correction des inégalités
de justice entre les générations c'est
pal et acquis accomplis par son système
de rétribution sont les familles elles
mêmes certains on doit tout autour de
nous des grands-parents qui peut être
évité en ont eu la chance d'avoir des
retraites préservé par rapport à celle
que seront les générations à venir
eh bien ce sont ses grands parents qui
aujourd'hui vont aider un petit enfant à
s'installer à démarrer dans la vie
et c'est donc voyez le fait de pointer
une catégorie de manière statique prend
pas compte de cette réelle sévérité qui
est déjà à l'oeuvre
et c'est sûr qu'un retraité qui va aider
ses enfants ses petits-enfants ou autour
de lui mais vit assez mal d'être pointés
du doigt comme ça ensuite il ya un choix
un choix économique du gouvernement qui
peut se défendre et difficile qui n'est
pas conscient n'a quoi et pour le fond
qu'un choix accomplir courageux en ce
sens oui va à rebours de la populaire
était facile qui consiste à dire voilà
je veux mettre le paquet sur le travail
donc sur toute la richesse qui va
permettre de créer du travail et donc
l'argent que j'aime être sur la création
du travail donc par exemple les baisses
des charges des entreprises bien je vais
en mettre un peu moins dans la de
retraités ça peut se justifier ça peut
se défendre mais le problème c'est qu'il
ya un effet cumulatif
il ya un discours global qui donne le
sentiment pas tant de d'appeler les
autres à les former
pas prendre en compte ne pas prendre en
considération ne pas prendre en
considération ces retraités on peut
demander aux gens de faire des efforts
mais quand on leur tient un langage du
respect et d'accompagnement pas quand on
semble les montrer du doigt écoutez ces
quelques réactions elles ont été
recueillies aujourd'hui lors de des
manifestations dont je vous parlais à
l'instant sur 16 millions noté t il ya
là deux millions qui sont déjà sous le
seuil de la pauvreté
on commence à voir des taxes tourne bien
alors qu'on a travaillé 44 ans 45 ans
qu'on a mis 30 ans pour payer nous nous
mêlons avec 200 euros par mois pour
vivre en région parisienne c'est
absolument impossible
depuis deux ans je pense moi perdu 10%
de pouvoir d'achat entre la cg la
non-revalorisation on sait à peu près ce
qu'on a perdu et effectivement tout cela
pour que monsieur macro puisse financer
l'impôt sur la fortune des spéculateurs
des témoignages recueillis par rt france
matteo et alberti c'est légitime cette
protestation des retraités
je suis je partage l'avis de guillaume
tabard sur le fait qu' on stigmatise en
tout cas une classe de la population
comme si elle avait eu quelques il avait
commis quelques fautes parce que elle a
accumulé entre guillemets de l'argent
mais effectivement comme le disait aussi
cette retraitée qui manifestait déjà
habité à paris où habitait dans
dil des préférences c'est différent et
puis n'oublions pas que il ya toujours
le discours de la du droit a passé la
richesse qu'on a quand même pas
seulement accumuler mais on dira à
conserver et fait fructifier à nos
enfants à aux générations suivantes donc
ce que je trouve vraiment on y re
bizarre pour un gouvernement c'est de
l'ignorer que de toute façon il ya aussi
beaucoup de retraités qui commence à
prendre la voie de pays européennes qui
ont fait de l'attraction de par exemple
le portugal
leur marque de fabrique est donc plan
d'aidé
vous serez traités européens non
seulement français vont là bas parce que
plus chaud il faut bien etc
et quand c'est une question que l'on
devrait se poser pourquoi je dois
m'expatrier pour garder ce qui est ce
que je finalement gagné pendant toute ma
vie quant à notre cas maintenant mais je
veux dire c'est assez une question de
sécurité d'eads et aussi de justice
c'est insupportable de voir encore une
fois que qu'on met une étiquette sur les
personnes âgées retraités et c'est
surtout parce qu'ils vont aussi
participer à des efforts alors ce qui
concerne les frais sanitaire parce que
quand en plus on habitait par exemple en
provence et on n'a pas l'accès à tout de
suite des médicaments etc à soumont doit
prendre un taxi ayant de la fin le coût
de la vie pour une personne âgée qui
doit se maintenir en bonne santé parfois
c'est plus important que sur tout avec
une espérance de vie qui augmente selon
ton sort est joué on vous pose la
question sur twitter est ce que selon
vous le gouvernement s'attaque trop
retraités bas là non plus ce n'est pas
une surprise complète vous êtes très
majoritairement à 83% vous répondez oui
à cette question gepetto nous dit sur
lefigaro.fr pourquoi un tel acharnement
envers les retraités et l'on nous dit il
faut laisser les retraités et commencé
par baisser les dépenses de l'état alors
même si monsieur babineau nuance il ya
une certaine cohérence cas la priorité
c'est de relancer l'économie et mettre
la nouvelle génération dans les
meilleures conditions
c'est vrai philippe meyer l'argent il
faut aller le chercher là où il est et
ce qui n'est pas précisément là où il
est c'est à dire l'argent public et est
ce que la question de l'orientation de
la dépense publique d'une amélioration
de la dépense publique d'une
amélioration de son contrôle que la cour
des comptes appelle de ses voeux de
manière très précise tous les ans sur
beaucoup de sujets en pure perte
la plupart du temps en pure perte je
peux vous dire je préside une
association qui a été contrôlée par la
chambre régionale des comptes nous
sommes sortis avec les félicitations du
jury mais je peux vous dire que ils ont
entre vraiment très très en détail et
que je
voit que c'est la même chose pour les
administrations sauf que nous si on
avait été pris en photo leur est payé
cher que les administrations ne sont
comptables de rien d'ailleurs l'état
n'est comptable derrière l'état peut
vous venez vous pouvez gagner un procès
contre l'état
mais comme pouvait pas le saisir ça ne
sert à rien et vous en êtes vous en êtes
pour vos frais donc il ya cet été c'est
à cet aspect des choses il ya aussi
cette mix est comment dire
ce filtre pour apprécier la réalité qui
est une espèce de filtre ni idéologique
me statistiques alors il ya des chiffres
alors c'est vrai que on a mieux vécu
quand on avait vingt ou trente ans dans
les trente glorieuses que maintenant
c'était plus facile de trouver du
travail c'était plus facile de trouver
un bon salaire c'est plus facile de
changer d'emploi etc
il y avait de la rédaction pour financer
la carte mais il y avait de l'inflation
aujourd'hui on nous dit que le lot cdo
je crois dit que en 2020 les retraités
perdront 400 euros mais comme c'est sur
une base d'inflation qui est comme ça
tirait au doigt mouillé on sait pas très
bien ce que ça veut dire c'est mes
pronos prenons un exemple si on
s'intéresse à la réalité comme vous
l'avez tous les deux réclamé la réalité
de beaucoup de ces retraités qui aident
leurs enfants ou leurs petits enfants
c'est sa place par l'immobilier on
achète de quoi loger ceux de ses petits
enfants qui vont faire des études ou qui
vont rentrer en apprentissage 20 ans
mais à lyon à paris ailleurs là là là où
c'est très cher et la caisse qui
arrivent ils arrivent l'impôt sur la
fortune immobilière
si vous êtes retraité que vous habitez
par exemple l'aveyron qui est à vendre '
nous encourager venu en avaient vraiment
froid sans péridurale vos départements
du monde
ne soyons pas restrictif
si vous habitez l'aveyron vous avez un
petit fils qui fait des qui fait des
études à paris vous avez
où acheter un studio c'est une résidence
secondaire c'est résidents secondaires
est taxée au maximum des maximum ce qui
fait que si vous n'êtes pas retraités
fortunés
ça ça vous rend la vie extrêmement
difficiles toutes ces choses là c'est à
dire de qui s'agit-il quand on parle des
retraités
nous ne savons pas nous ne voulons pas
le savoir' d'ailleurs c'est on considère
que simplement ce sont des gens qui ont
des revenus plus confortable que le vin
assez confortable pour contribuer
contribuer à quoi à l'impôt n'oublions
pas qu'il ya aussi des retraités qui
essayent qui veulent travailler parce
que qu'ils continuaient à travailler
c'est devenu plus facile christophe de
gorji oui je voudrais juste donné une
petite dissonances quand même n'oublions
pas quand on entend le re le
syndicaliste qui nous avons travaillé 40
45 ans je suis désolé c'est pas vrai du
tout pour cette génération là puisque
justement à l'abbé la retraite au bout
de 37 ans et demi il faut quand même le
rappeler deuxièmement vous savez
connaissez la france on crie avant
d'avoir mal
on crie encore plus fort quand on a mal
mais on crie encore encore plus fort
quand tout va bien
de peur de perdre c'est déjà écrit par
rousseau d'ailleurs de peur de perdre le
peu houleux beaucoup qu'on a dans cette
affaire je pense que ma croix était
quand même sur ce point parfaitement
clair il a annoncé la couleur avec la
csg et les retraités qui n'ont pas lu
son programme là quand même peuvent
peut-être s'en prendre à eux mêmes
ce que je voudrais dire c'est qu'il de
là encore c'est une question de
pédagogie et de rhétorique
quand il dit je veux favoriser le
travail les gens le prennent très mal
parce qu'ils ont travaillé toute leur
vie c'est pas du tout comme ça qu'il
faut présenter les choses il dit il faut
il faut je veux favoriser les catégories
actives 1 mais pas du tout le travail
les gens disent surtout alors nous on
est des paresseux vous avez entendu la
réaction
bref les là il ya vraiment un problème
de pédagogie et de rhétorique et de
maladresses et que vous savez gagner
quelques unes mais je pense quand même
que sur le fond on ne peut pas dire
qu'il a raconté du pipeau il a bien dit
qu'il allait favorise qu'il allait
défavorisés les retraités le problème
c'est que les retraités ont voté
massivement pour lui et que l' étape
dans le coeur de l'électorat
le vrai problème à moi les lourds macron
c'est pas forcément les retraités c'est
les classes moyennes parce qu'elle
classe moyenne ont voté pour lui et les
classes moyennes alors là du point de
vue taxe alors je dirais retraités
compris plus largement les classes
moyennes
sont vraiment actuellement les dindons
de la farce fiscale elle profite moi
effectivement d'aider des baisses
d'impôts annoncées en tout cas en début
de quinquennat pour les plus favorisés
on change de sujet pour parler de la pm
à la procréation médicalement assistée
on attend un projet de loi du
gouvernement pour l'extension de cette
procédure au couple de lesbiennes et aux
femmes seules
on avait le sentiment qu'il ya vous
pouvez y avoir une opposition de la
droite à ce type de projet eh ben ça
n'est pas si évident que ça valérie
pécresse la présidente de l'est
républicain de la région ile de france
l'a dit dimanche dernier au grand jury
rtl le figaro lci
elle n'est pas contre à condition que y
ait des garde fous entre guillemets qui
soit installée
c'est aussi point de vue gérard larcher
le président du sénat il est lui aussi
républicain et il était ce matin sur
france info regardez moi personnellement
position je ne refuse pas la pma un
certain nombre de conditions liées à la
parentalité
je pense la levée de l'anonymat sur le
don de gamètes ce que je veux être c'est
le porte-voix de deux revendications
l'accès aux origines des enfants le
droit à l'accès aux origines et la non
marchandisation du corps humain ce
seront mes deux combats à ces conditions
valérie pécresse ne semble pas opposée à
eau à la pma pour les couples de femmes
guillaume tabard ça vous surprend cette
ces deux prises de positions non elle
était totalement prévisible et je peux
même l'annoncé l'érection future de ces
mêmes dirigeants sert qu'une fois que la
pma sera votée bien sûr sans aucune des
garanties qu'elles réclament aujourd'hui
la frontière sera nommé au quai c'est
fait mais nous ne nous opposons la gpa
parce que c'est la partie natation du
corps telles qu'on n'aurait pas assez et
puis ensuite lorsque le combat des
partisans de cela avant seront ils
diront âgées perdent oui mais à
condition que la gpa éthique avec un
centre de garde-fous lesquels garde-fous
n'existeront pas et ainsi de suite
on revit exactement les mêmes pièces
dans un scénario qui avaient commencé
dès 1999 avec le pacs souvenez vous
lorsque
le pacs était débattu proposé par le
gouvernement jospin et
et que certains disent attention le pacs
nous annoncent le mariage homosexuel
la garde des sceaux en premier league il
n'ya vous agiter des fantasmes pour
faire peur aux gens ça a bien évidemment
il n'y en a déjà mis ne sera jamais
question du mariage et ainsi de suite et
assemble de gens de droite le problème
c'est que on a d'un côté à gauche des
gens qui ont un sens au nombre de deux
de vision des choses une anthropologie
pour prier en un mot c'est un gros mot
mais une autre peau logis qui qu'ils
descendent même lorsqu'elle est
minoritaire dans l'opinion et qu'on a
souvent en face une droite qui ne
réfléchit pas ou qu'il n'a pas attaché à
une réflexion anthropologique et qui
adapte sa position à ce qu'elle croit
est la position dominante de l'opinion
donc tant que l'opinion et des médias
mais même de l'opinion globalement
lorsque la droite avait sentiment que le
pinot étaient majoritairement contre le
mariage homosexuel a été contre
lorsqu'il a vu que son jason retourner
elles ont basculé hélas pour les pma ce
à quoi on assiste pendant longtemps
edouard philippe le premier lorsqu'il
était encore député jean pradier
nous nous opposerons fermement la pm at
c à l'époque l'opinion était
majoritairement contre là on voit que
les sondages bouge et bien les mêmes
dirigeants de droite une grande partie
dirigeants de droite adaptent leurs et
voyez est un combat lorsqu'on un combat
est mené non pas par conviction mais par
calcul politique
il est toujours perdue d'avancé ligne à
ce que dit guillaume tabard poliment
c'est que les gens de droite n'ont pas
beaucoup de conviction
je sais pas où sont ils les ont rangé
mais je dirais que même les réseaux
sociaux leur foute une pétoche terrible
c'est qu'il ya une phrase de bernanos
dans leur diagnocure mais dit il dit qu'
il se repasse la peur comme on se refile
le choléra et c'est exactement ce qui
domine dans la vie publique pas
seulement à droite il faut dire
d'ailleurs
et en effet dans les médias est en effet
dans les médias qui faute d'avoir cette
vieille tradition du reportage qui fait
qu'on a un peu une idée de ce qui se
passe dans la société regarde sur
facebook et sur twitter
mon dieu et se met à trembler à l'idée
qu'ils aient que ce qu'ils dénonceraient
ne seraient pas approuvés par les
réseaux sociaux donc oui on peut avoir
toutes les positions qu'on veut à propos
de la pma mais qu'on en est une sacré
nom d'un chien est pas une qui changent
en fonction d'eux des humeurs du moment
et en plus qui ne se plante pas derrière
ces mots fermement éthique garantie qui
veulent absolument dire le contraire de
ce qu'ils sont censés dire your pas de
fermeté quant à l'éthique
il ira se faire voir ailleurs et les
garanties on les cherchera vainement on
vous interroge sur twitter selon vous la
pma pour tout conduira-t-elle forcément
à la gpa et vous répondez oui à 63%
relents ne développe sa réponse si le
principe est accepté alors les
techniques s'imposeront et évolueront
peut-être au-delà même de la gpa et de
notre imagination et anti mac dit sa
conviction aujourd'hui on nous dit que
c'est non mais à terme je pense qu'on
sera obligé d'autoriser le la gpa on va
y revenir à ce sujet de la de la
gestation pour autrui
mais mateus alberti pour rester sur la
la pma en fait on se demande d'où peut
venir l'opposition peut-être de l'église
catholique du coup sans doute l'église
catholique est le seul la seule
institution entre guillemets au parti de
la société qu'enseignement s'opposent
d'une façon claire à 7 à cette pratique
il faut dire que dans la droite il y a
des
un marché électoral parce que valérie
pécresse c'est en train elle aussi de
regarder à la prochaine élection
sauf que encore une fois vous avez sous
les yeux les résultats des législatives
la droite elle a fait quoi je ne me
rappelle plus mais pas beaucoup
je prends rappelait le poids de la
droite au parlement à l'assemblée
nationale est plutôt comment dire
limiter un enseignement aussi parce que
la droite a pris l'antenne de députés
avoir à payer aussi une trentaine de
centristes de saint-brice de l a payé
peut-être toutes ces positions qui ne
sont pas claires sur tout un tas
d'arguments est aussi serein l'éthique
parce qu'encore une fois il faut dire
que l'opposition de l'église est la
seule mais en ce moment aussi l'église
passe un mauvais moment et sans faire de
sans mélanger les torchons avec les
serviettes mais il faut dire que c'est
un peu difficile d'entendre parler
d'éthique de respecter de l'enfant de
droits de l'enfant et avoir tous les
situations tout le fait que l'église ne
fait pas encore assez de
ménage dans son sang dans ses rangs les
infirmiers on n'aborde pas le sujet de
la pédophilie comme il faudrait
christophe devaux oui je crois qu'on est
dans ce que souleymane l'appelaient les
schizophrénies française en l'occurrence
ou signale tout de même que légalement
les enfants en question eux sont
reconnues si la chose interdite les
enfants y compris de gpa sont reconnues
je vous signale aussi que le conseil
d'état l'on loue lui vient de dire de
donner un avis négatif à l'extension de
la pma aux lesbiennes
donc attention c'est légalement s'est
pas encore complètement acquis mais
évidemment évidemment le principe
d'égalité dire que les garçons dont dire
et il n'y a pas de raison que les filles
aient le droit d'avoir des enfants et
pas nous et donc il y aura le principe
d'égalité est à mon avis la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme à jour
va se prononcer et elle va se prononcer
s'il ya la paix mais pma pour la gpa à
terme mais les combats sont pas terminés
et regardez le conseil d'état vient de
prendre une décision extrêmement conseil
d'état si j'ose dire
c'est à dire l'intérêt général au nom de
l'intérêt général personne ne comprend
très bien ce que ça veut dire en
l'occurrence et vous allez voir que ça
va déclencher une polémique
un petit détail sémantique aussi parce
que les idées les combats ils avancent
aussi parler
par les mots alors à reprendre des
débats plus ancien encore mais
aujourd'hui parlent que le mot
avortement n'est plus utilisé ou non pas
que la prédation en france quelle
relation ivg qui est neutre et qu'il ya
moins l'effet choc pour une nié la
réalité de ce que représentent les
sépare en italie matteo avec votre
accent ch'ti de les agresser
on utilise le mot apporte extra-forte
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de fait mise
1-2 et si on allait perdre vous ne vous
même
jaggi absolument vous ne nous parlait de
la gestion pour autrui et dans ceux dans
cette appellation le pour autrui une
dimension d'altruisme de dons de
générosité si vous parlez par contre de
gestation par autrui car en fait c'est
ça la gestation par autrui c'est faire
porter un enfant par quelqu'un d'autre
que celui qui on aura la fin n'était pas
rentable après on voit bien que c'est
différent et que le fait qu'on impose le
mot pour autrui veut insérer installer
cette cette pratique dans une vision qui
se veut généreuse et bakol ans lorsqu'à
bataille des mots et gagner d'un côté ou
perdu de l'autre ça oriente aussi la
suite du débat c'est de la même façon
selon qu'on dit pma pour tout ou pma
sans père évidemment on n'a pas tout à
fait la même vision des choses et vous
parliez vous parlez de la de la gpa qui
obtint bas notre confrère marc olivier
fogiel qui a eu deux filles par gpa avec
son mari vient d'écrire un livre sur le
sujet écoutez le et expliquer les
échanges qu'il a eus avec la mère
porteuse de ses enfants
un matin il nous a envoyé un sms et elle
nous a écrit we were president on est
enceinte mais voilà si vous me demandez
ce que je suis d'abord je la vois pas je
crois que depuis quelques années je
pleure tous les jours je pleurais pas
beaucoup à jour on met là le le débat
délibérément sur le registre de
l'émotion philippe meyer et on se dit
voit pas forcément
pas facile de de vouloir contrarier ce
genre de sentiment écoutez c'est
embêtant parce que on voit là c'est son
expérience personnelle en même temps on
voit bien que c'est l'utilisation de
notoriété pour pour éviter un débat j'ai
tout à l'heure on a assisté a justement
la loi arrive juste au moment où la lave
arrive évidemment c'est pas que ça fait
quand même pas mal de temps que cette
situation que fogiel et perd tout à
l'heure on a assisté à un débat un
concours entre madame pécresse et
monsieur larcher pour dire mauriac moi
pas du tout alors ça vraiment mauvais
passage eu un peu de droite mais je suis
vraiment pareil et là maintenant bon
alors évidemment cette émotion est
probablement réel ya aucune raison de la
mettre en doute mais qu'est ce qu'elle
vient faire nar chacun d'entre nous
pourrait sur un autre sujet ou sur ce
sujet là présenter quelque chose qui ait
la même charge émotive simplement tout
le monde n'a pas une notoriété qui
permet de se serrer ça j'aime pas ça je
déteste ça pour tout dire mais
évidemment ça ne valent que marc olivier
fogiel vive sa vie et qu'il soit heureux
et que ses filles ne deviennent à leur
tour mais je pourrais préféré que sommes
n'arrive pas matthews averti vous vous
disiez en italie gpa saah sah se dit pas
de cette façon-là utilise l'expression
août héroïne afit ça veut dire utérus en
location et c'est beaucoup plus on dire
ça fait tout de suite alors que
exactement mais la rhétorique
voilà c'est quelque chose que encore une
fois peut-être vous parlez de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme je suis
désolé de parler encore une fois des
européennes mais je pense qu'il y aura
des surprises et la composition du
parlement aura aussi des implications
sur la composition de la commission
européenne et peut-être dans le choix
des deux juges qui arriveront des
différents pays
donc je sais pas peut-être l'opposition
vous me demandez tout à l'heure
l'opposition rivera aussi de l'étranger
je sais que tu es comme indo européen
enfin c'est se pencher sur le dernier
sujet il nous reste quelques minutes
pour cela je le disais au début de
l'émission
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
est en train de
faire examiner sa loi pacte au parlement
cette loi prévoit notamment des cessions
de participations de l'état
par exemple dans aéroports de paris dans
francs dans la française des jeux ou
dans le groupe énergétique
angie est ce que c'est une bonne idée on
a posé la question de façon un peu
direct christophe de voogd faut-il
vendre les bijoux de famille alors
écoutez cette expression laudative pour
le coup les bijoux de famille à propos
de l'entreprise publique mais j'ai
toujours un peu sourire parce qu'il ya
là parce qu'on a pas mal de vie joue en
toc
en l'occurrence il ya quand même pas mal
d'entreprises publiques allaient je veux
pas être méchant mais je pense à
certaines qui sont très bien difficile à
vendre même même mettre en location au
mont-de-piété donc attention à ces
facettes expression bijoux de famille on
a vraiment se laissait pas le cas aux
portes de paris c'est mon table je pense
qu'un contrat à d'autres sociétés qui
vont très mal d'accord l'état étant pas
vraiment le meilleur gestionnaire ni le
meilleur actionnaire je dirais même ni
nos meilleurs actionnaires vous savez
qu'il a tendance à pompe et ses
entreprises et il se comporte bien plus
férocement qu'un fonds de pension
d'autres d'autre part je suis persuadé
que je peux dire ce gros mot sur ce
plateau je peux pas le dire partout mais
étant un libéral vous imaginez que j'ai
tendance à penser que le gouvernement a
autre chose à faire
et s'il ya des bijoux de famille en
france et dieu sait qu'il y en a c'est
plutôt le patrimoine et je crois qu'il
faudrait peut-être que le le
gouvernement et l'état assure et pas
seulement par les magnifiques efforts de
stéphane bern
mais par lui-même l'entretien de nos
vrais bijoux de famille alors on va
écouter un parlementaire qui va tout à
fait dans votre sens c'est charles de
courson est un député centriste c'est
aussi vice président de la commission
des finances de l'assemblée nationale
est pour lui une très bonne idée de
privatiser les entreprises publiques
pour une raison très simple c'est que
l'état ne s'est pas les gérer regardez
le capitalisme d'état a été globalement
un échec en france
échec dans le choix des dirigeants vous
croyez que la patronne d'areva
si ç'avait été une boîte privée aurait
pu faire ce qu'elle a fait qui va coûter
15 milliards aux contribuables français
si tu avais une boîte privée elle aurait
été viré vite fait bien fait par son
conseil d'administration
message personnel à l'attention d'anne
lauvergeon
on vous pose la question sur twitter
selon vous l'état doit-il privatiser
angie adp la fdj
vous répondez non araud a quasiment les
deux tiers et vous guillaume tabard que
répondez vous écoutez je réponds que je
n'ai pas compétence ont tous les sujets
je suis pas économisé pas s'arranger pas
d'avis qui fasse autorité où bon vous
n'avez pas de position de principe en
tout cas je vois deux en principe
spontanément spontanément je me dis que
il n'y a pas de raison que l'état fasse
ce que d'autres peuvent faire à sa place
ils peuvent faire mieux je suis assez
sensible parce que dit charles de
courson je pense que construit des
voitures
pas besoin que l'état le
le fasse et d'ailleurs l'état finit par
se désengager des constructeurs
automobiles dans le qualité il était
inquiet qui s'emporte d'autant mieux
voilà alors après dans les entreprises
qu'ils ont cité la notamment à des petra
et la question c'est est-ce que d'agnès
entreprise il ya autre chose simplement
qu'une entreprise qui doit tourner faire
des profits pour le point faible de
l'ensemble de l'économie
bon beaucoup de gens disent d'action les
aéroports c'est aussi une frontière
donc est-ce qu'on peut privatiser une
frontière angie c'est aussi des choix
qui touche aux stratégiques nucléaires
etc
est-ce qu'on peut ben voilà alors après
je pense que c'est à l'état aussi de
définir dans des cahiers des charges
jacente de deux principes de règles de
garde fou est aussi deux derniers points
lorsque la logique cyniquement la l'état
qui cherche à tout prix de l'argent si
c'est juste pour grappiller un peu de un
peu d'euros et diminuer les déficits
c'est insuffisant si c'est au service
d'une vraie vision in d'une raie
stratégie sur l'économie
tout peut se défendre alors vous adp ou
aéroports de paris où la française des
jeux
ce sont aussi des monopoles et ceux qui
sont hostiles aux privatisations donne
par exemple exemple des autoroutes
n'importe qui peut pas créer une
autoroute en disant regardez on les a
privatisé le résultat des courses c'est
que ça coûte un bras aux français quand
ils veulent les prendre
matteo csel verte si vous avez un point
de vue sur ce sujet c'est je pense aux
autres autrement je pense à à gènes cet
été autoroute privatiser un état dit
aussi on a eu pas mal de privatisations
à partir des années 90 c'était très
grande je pense que
pour privatiser il faut penser d'abord à
la possibilité de faire des économies
dans l'est comme le conseil d'état la
cour est content de le suggérer mais
aussi au fait qu' il faut être sûr que
d'ici 20 ans ses infrastructures et ses
joyaux de famille bijoux de famille ne
soit pas effectivement nécessaire a
affirmé une sorte d'autorité aussi sur
un certain territoire qui est le
territoire d'un état donc peut-être une
voie possible c'est celle de créer une
espèce de fond peut-être entre certains
pays
peut-être un niveau européen et c'est
aussi pour se protéger un peu plus
vis-à-vis des concurrents chinois et
américains je n'ai pas les compétences
pour dire à quelle est la forme
juridique de ce type d'institution mais
disons que si les états effectivement on
pouvait se libérer de quelque chose qui
est lourd mais qui restait quelque part
au service de leurs de leur système free
structurale ça sera notamment l'ip
meilleur vous avez un point de vue sur
moi je suis pour les privatisations à
condition qu'une garantie ferme et
éthiques
autant dire que ça soit comme pour les
autoroutes par exemple c est aussi comme
pour les partenariats public-privé dont
on s'aperçoit que dans ces situations
dans ces partenariats
le public c'est georges d'onde et donc
non je suis désolé mais on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui en tout cas sans compter la
question des aéroports aucun aéroport
américain ni intérieure ni à la
frontière n'est privatiser ils sont tous
québec
pourtant c'est au son du bal hostilement
a vraiment libéré le 30 mai mme 30 n'a
pas proposé de privatiser les aéroports
donc en l'état actuel la fois d aussi
pour la raison que vous avez dit parce
qu'on a vraiment l'impression que faut à
tout prix la retrouver quelque chose
parce que sinon on va pas pouvoir les
récupérer au mont-de-piété la vieille
normand et donc non c'est pas possible
tu entends qu on a affaire à alors
certes évidemment l'état n'est sans
doute pas l exemple d'areva extrêmement
puissant et du crédit lyonnais avant et
après et ailleurs non et non seulement
crédit lyonnais et mais commençons par
faire en sorte que l'état réforme sans
son utilisation de la dépense publique
est peut-être après on peut songer avant
mais là en l'état on a on on perd sur
les deux tableaux
je vais vous répondre quelle garantie
d'avoir c'est vrai que c'est un peu une
solution de facilité
on dit alors c'est mieux en anglais mais
on dit l'année 73 qui dit vendre larges
entrées pour payer le boucher s'est pas
forcément comme ça qu'on gère bien un
pays à risque c'est toujours les
questions de l'étatisme français qui se
portent aussi bien à droite qu'à gauche
mais je rappelle quand même sur
l'autoroute fait des autoroutes juste
une précision
j'ai pas souvenir que l est pas qu ils
étaient publiques elle était si bon
marché et je constate et tout le monde
de cons
tat tout bon de constater que la qualité
du service depuis qu'elles sont
privatisés s'est énormément amélioré
notamment les aires autoroutières et ça
il faut il faut donc faire un peu la
part des choses deuxièmement en matière
de sécurité du transport
alors là les statistiques sont
impitoyables les chemins de fer qui ont
les meilleurs taux de sécurité en europe
sur les chemins de fer privés
c'est le chemin de fer britannique et le
chemin de fer suisses donc et la sncf
malheureusement vous parlez de gênes
vous avez raison mais les accidents de
la sncf
la grande différence entre le privé et
le public c'est qu'il n'ya tant que
public poules avait rappelé la jeu de
philippe meyer il n'y a jamais de
responsables jamais guillaume tabac
c'est encore un marqueur de droite
la privatisation ou bien comme tout le
monde en fait aujourd'hui c'est une
mesure de gestion comme une autre octo
oui ça fait longtemps je pense que ça
n'est plus un clivage gauche droite le
le dernier grand combat idéologique
c'est lé début des années 80
mitterrand qui nationalise en 81 et
chirac qui privatise en 86 depuis tous
les gouvernements y ont eu recours
et je crois même rôle que le record de
présentation c'est sous le nom de jospin
pas vraiment de la demande droite ce
qu'on peut simplement espérer comme
contribuable c'est que l'état vende au
bon prix et qu'ils ne se fassent pas
avoir parce que la cour des comptes
encore elle a relevé dans le passé un
certain nombre d'affaires quand été
meilleure pour les acheteurs privés que
pour les vendeurs public voilà point de
vue c'est fini pour ce soir merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'y avoir
participé
vous retrouvez à ce même endroit demain
à la même heure marie-amélie l'amba
bonsoir
[Musique]